[Music]
what that noise behind you welcome back
to vile villager the show where we play
as the meanest biggest POS in Animal
Crossing New Horizons
Jake we took a two-week hiatus because
of a bunch of game releases a lot of
stuff going on but now we're back and I
also have been able to put a little more
time in so we can expedite this slow
burn of a game point being we now have
three new villagers coming to this
island - oh yeah - are already here so
we're gonna look at them and then the
big-ticket item
challenge today is can we lock all of
our animal friends in cages we have
fences we have logs we have means of
catching them up just like the tiger
king himself and also Jake Antonio today
gave me this reaction or a motion and
it's very suiting what a [ __ ] you
should know you're gonna do that to him
now Jake I've done a little bit of work
here this will get better and better you
know what as you can see we have our
perfect [ __ ] top here I mean it's ice
cream but let's face it they know what
they were doing this is yeah so here's
here's the entrance this is a fossil
Persia gave us this and it's wonderful I
got some skeletons it's like your time
skipping - because I see Daisy Mae here
and it's Thursday no man I'm playing
this normally so here's another thing
I'd like to share is that I figured we
only the only flowers I mean this purple
ones a little a little off-putting but
the only flowers we have in our island
black that works for me that that check
trans Twitter can't get like brown
flowers
yeah Brown will be pretty good so here's
a tire this is office chair I don't know
how I got that there's obviously got
some tires in the ground yeah I got some
tires here we're getting there dude so I
bought this today this is my little meth
lab I am the danger I am the one who
needs a little bit of sneeze snot in
there - that's the pile touch perfect
that's a pile superhero persona I
thought this was fairly upsetting yeah
that's that's uncomfortable I don't like
that did I spell one Z right am i I
don't know who cares good enough okay
that's all I wanted to do so here's the
best part you want to see my magic wand
your iron one like how vile puts this on
because he thinks the villagers won't
recognize him oh this is by the way the
the dog food that vile eats every
morning you just runs out of his house
Kicks down the door and well let's see
who's outside well I guess we can meet
them because we can't fence him in
inside no let's meet our our first new
arrival what does bio think of bacon
those are death eyes he's dead alright
so he's not gonna leave his house today
it's cool I'm wearing a bag what do you
think I put the bag on this morning
oh there's a me oh there's a Antonio
wait wait yeah you keep pumping good you
keep pumping
there we go there you go
Tony oh I hope you like fishing Antonio
that's one that's one now we got to wait
for the other ones leave their house
well do we want it just come back in or
do we want to skip a day and see who our
new friend is up to you all right I say
we skip a day don't show this Tammy all
right we should check on I should check
on Antonio's if he's still stuck please
want to get called sneezing so she knows
welcome to the neat house
ah oh you escaped
[Music]
what was that noise behind you oh look
he's just going there himself what ii
got ya see ya
alright doll okay get over here
no it doesn't
yeah we're pushing you so slowly and
carefully hey by the way everyone I'm
really wow I had you all fooled
yeah we are having fun with fences
[Laughter]
Antonio knows there's they're trying to
defend the Antonio they know that we
like Antonio the most we like you the
most Antonio oh oh oh god is going
[Music]
oh sorry gala I mean I can manually push
a baby there's no fun in that
right I'm Tony oh no fun in that there's
no yeah piss way to go in Tony oh all
he's even more pissed you get the food
though did you get dog food that's gonna
do it for this week's episode stay tuned
next week we'll have another one you
have any ideas or suggestions on how to
continue biles goal of being the biggest
POS ever please put them in the comment
sections and we'll take a look
Thank You Jake and see you guys next
week see you next week
you
[Music]